Now we run into an interesting concept. Is that we'd like to have our robots
move around the screen, which presents a problem. Currently our canvas
coordinates are the same as our map coordinates. Such that tiles 00 on the map
renders to location 00 on the canvas, but as our robot moves around We want them
to stay at the center of the screen and background move around accordingly. In
order to properly translate to canvas we have to separate those two coordinate
systems. Such that we can map the translated world value to the canvas
coordinates to accurately draw. Your goal, if you choose to accept it, is to
write a function that will translate the map to center around a given x, y pair.
For instance, if we call center at 00, then the top left corner of the map 00,
should render at the center of the canvas. Center is 256 by 256. Should put the
map coordinates of 256, 256. In the world space at the center of the canvas.
Now, write a function that will translate the map to center around a given x, y
pair. For instance, if we call center at 00 then the top left corner of the map
00, should render at the center of the canvas. Center at 256 by 256 should do
the corollary thing, placing coordinates of 256, 256 in world space at the
center of the canvas. Now, notice you'll actually need to know the canvas width
and canvas height when computing this data so you know where is the center of
the canvas.